[MUSIC]
My grandma is my queen.
Engineer by education, she started her
career as a rocket scientist at 22.
At 46, she became director
of a summer camp for kids.
At 69, she left this position, no, not for
retirement, but
to become an HR manager for
the rocket science company
she used to work before.
She retired only 13 years later, at 82,
beloved by everyone who was
lucky enough to work with her.
She's now 88, and my god,
you should see the flowers and
veggies she's growing
at her country house.
My grandma's career path,
with it's multiple pivots into her 80s,
is extraordinary for
her time, but she's a forerunner
of how a career should look like.
Nowadays we have a good chance
to live until 100 and beyond.
We are ageing so much healthfully,
this is exciting.
We can accomplish so
much more during our lifetime.
But to take advantage of
this gift of a long life,
we must prepare for career longevity.
I want to offer you three
ideas of how to do this.
Number one, start thinking of your career
as a portfolio, not as a straight line.
For many years, we have thought of a
successful career as of something linear,
it has a beginning, a peak and
an assumed decline.
The idea of career longevity
brings a portfolio approach.
Plan your career as a set of activities,
project,
directions, like my grandma.
Portfolio approach guarantees
more stability and more fun.
Stability is achieved by diversifying
your professional capabilities.
The world is changing so quickly,
professions rise and die, so do companies.
Just as in investing,
betting on just one thing is risky.
So diversify your career portfolio
to gain more stability and
lessen the risk of becoming irrelevant.
But also look at it from the fun angle.
You have gained an additional
30 years of life.
Some of that should definitely go
to doing something interesting.
Ask yourself, what else do I want to do?
Create a wish list and
start working on it now.
I try to keep the growing list for myself.
Start my own company,
do something for climate change,
become a lecturer at Stanford,
get a medical degree.
Suggestion number two is to
train yourself to be flexible.
It is very scary to adapt to rapid
changes, if you're not used to this.
Nowadays, the key competitive advantage
is how quickly one can handle
the uncertainty, adapt to new realities,
and learn new skills.
My practical advice to anyone,
regardless of age,
is to train yourself to be flexible
by studying something challenging.
Programming, a new foreign language, arts,
somethings that your brain doesn't like.
For me, it became math.
The last couple of years I've made myself
working on math problems every week.
In the beginning, it was torture,
but now it's fun.
Suggestion number three is more of an ask.
Shape the future by building
multi-generational teams.
Multi-generational teams
are rare in business now.
Younger people often resist
older employees, and
older employees sometimes struggle
to work within younger groups.
But actually,
research by Laura Carstensen at
the Stanford Center on Longevity indicates
that multi-generational teams are more
successful than only generational ones.
One of my best colleagues at
PWC was a retired partner,
who continued to engage with
student events well into his 60s.
It was amazing having someone
like him sharing his wisdom.
His energy was infectious, and I would
work with him again in a heartbeat.
I'm sure the people listening to me
today are leaders who are hiring.
My prime message to you is not to be
afraid to build multi-generational teams.
It is strategic for your business and
contributes to your
personal career longevity.
We can confidently say that
people in their 30s or
40s today will work another 40 or
50 years.
While we consider a career was multiple
pivots, there are basic skills like
communicating and collaborating with
people that should be mastered.
But this is an exciting, lifelong journey,
and you can start it today.
[MUSIC]